it sounds like a very mean and
undemocratic thought trading off the
peculiar glamour that isolation has in a
romantic culture in order to gain an
oblique sense of superiority and perhaps
pass off an absence of social skills as
a virtue it's important therefore to be
clear what is meant here by intelligence
it has nothing to do with degrees or any
of the criteria by which we ordinarily
measure cleverness what is meant is
emotional intelligence which exists or
not
in every strata and Nuuk of society
emotional intelligence means a capacity
for self honesty and self observation it
means a knack for opening oneself up to
the stranger more exciting less easily
admissible aspects of oneself and at the
same time for noticing the many
beautiful peculiar and profound
experiences and sensations passing
through consciousness we're not really
used to doing this we cleave tightly to
reassuring notions of what normal people
are like which means we exclude a lot
often the richest bit of what we truly
feel want and think we edit out are more
generous wilder more impatient more
terrifying sides leaving only the
socially admissible husk that we
artfully pretend is who we are and
simultaneously we ensure that we're
never far from something that can take
us powerfully away from ourselves and so
we miss out on a troubling wonders that
streak across the mental horizon at
every instant most of what is in our
minds remains unfelt
and unseen troubling us only in the
small hours insomnia is the revenge for
all that we tried so hard not to notice
in the daylight in this context
emotional intelligence emerges as a
species of courage directed at
vanquishing not an external enemy but a
fear of being weird or of going mad a
certain sort of intelligent person is
above all else a superior and more
committed reporter of their inner states
or as Emerson once put it in the minds
of geniuses we find once more our own
neglected thoughts it's almost certain
that people who have devoted themselves
to self honesty and self observation
have an above-average chance of meeting
within comprehension irritation
censorship or boredom when they attempt
to share the data from their own minds
frankly in company their thoughts it
might be on politics or architecture
family life or sexuality will sound more
threatening more intense oblique or
tender than is allowed that feels lonely
if one's in the mood to frame things
like this there is simply fewer people
at large committed to self honesty and
self observation and therefore up for
exchanging notes on what it's truly like
to be alive yet there is one resource
that is exceptionally well suited to
addressing the feelings of disconnection
liable to be felt by the emotionally
intelligent art works of art are
humanity's secret diary records of all
that could not be said in regular social
context but which have found a home in
the more intimate honest communication
that can take place between an artwork
and its audience the library's cinemas
and galleries of the world are
repositories for all the sensations that
didn't easily make it into standard
interactions and that contain what we
need to state and crave to hear as
audiences in our lonely States therefore
while emotionally intelligent people may
have an uncommon ly hard time not being
lonely with a person they have an
unusually easy time finding company with
people who are not in the room the fancy
term for what we call art we have
perhaps over privileged certain standard
notions of friendship we may just have
to accept that our best friends could
have died 250 years ago and be chatting
to us fire dabs of paint or with in
rhyming pentameters that said the goal
shouldn't be a society where art is ever
more prevalent and more available when
loneliness strikes it's perhaps a
society where art is ever less necessary
because we have grown better at knowing
how to share more of who we are in the
ordinary moments of our lives where we
have found a more direct and reliable
path out from our loneliness
if you liked this film please subscribe
to our channel and click the Bell icon
to turn on notifications most books that
want to change us seek to make us richer
or thinner this book wants to help us to
be nicer less irritable ready to listen
warmer people